[Applaudissements]
et tu chantes chantes chantes ce refrain
qui te plaît mais tu danses danses
chance c'est ta façon d'aimer et
reconnus ou pas oui jean ferrat les
chroniqueurs du csa les chroniqueurs de
touche pas à mon poste ont tous un
talent encaisser leurs chèques balancer
sur leurs collègues et être de bons
matches mais s'ils ont bien un talent
mais s'il ya bien un talent qu'ils n'ont
pas assez celui de chanter pour le ba ba
du poste du pire chanteur de l'ann e
les nommés sont à
dans la catégorie pire chanteur gilles
verdez
la guerre
[Musique]
cet événement dans la catégorie pire
chanteur
matthieu delormeau
de ce cas ci c'est cher
m
dans la catégorie pire chanteur jean
michel maire je vous dis merci comme les
autres effets secondaires
[Applaudissements]
et le gagnant est
jean jaurès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cg
trop content